one of marvel's lesser known heroes is
coming out of the shadows on disney plus
let's break down the symbolism
foreshadowing and music cues of the
first episode of moon knight including
that song you probably thought was jay-z
what are
you the moonlight series begins by
focusing not on the main character but
rather its villain arthur harrow in a
small but painful introduction as he
performs a ritual placing crushed glass
into his shoes for unknown reasons a
song every grain of sand by bob dylan is
heard playing on the soundtrack the
music's somber tone helps to set the
scene but more than that the words
suggest certain things about the plot
that will be revealed later they also
seem to illuminate the nature of arthur
harrow himself dylan's offering could be
studied in its entirety to relate to the
character on many levels but the most
notable line describes where he stands
and who he serves in the fury of the
moment i can see the master's hand dylan
later sings i hear the ancient footsteps
like the motion of the sea sometimes i
turn there's someone there other times
it's only me considering where the
series seems to be heading exploring the
fractured personality of its protagonist
and the influence of the gods on normal
people it's a prescient line that says a
lot about where the show seems to be
going the intro may be a brief scene but
it leaves a strong impression and is way
more meaningful than it appears at first
glance
as steven grant is leaving his job at
the museum much of the audience will be
focused on the interaction between him
and the security guard whom steven
corrects for calling him the wrong name
that's a bit of foreshadowing unto
itself but many viewers might notice a
familiar flute sound playing in the
background one that sounds unmistakably
like the beat for big pimpin by jay-z a
weird song choice right turns out it's
not that song at all for big pimpin
timberland and jay-z sampled kosara
kosara a 1957 piece by bali hamdi in
their song this led to a years-long
court case from the family of hamdi who
claimed copyright infringement over
improper use of the song even though the
case was eventually thrown out of course
it shed a greater light on how arabic
artists influenced western music
ramsay's version is a tune being played
in the scene even though most viewers
wouldn't catch that right away it's an
egyptian piece of music that helps to
show how moon knights will be embracing
a culture so centrally tied to the
character
it's also just an incredibly catchy tune
it has to be weird to find an unfamiliar
flip phone hidden in your home
especially when it has 30 plus missed
calls from someone else's ex amongst the
many notifications of layla though
sticks out the singular instance of
another caller duchamp though the name
is clearly important it won't ring any
bells for those unfamiliar with the
comics the character who mark spector
calls frenchie is a big part of the
books but it doesn't look like we will
be seeing him in the show just yet
jean-paul duchamp was a soldier like
spectre but one who joined the french
legion he was a mercenary when the two
met he spent many issues fighting
alongside his comrade not only as a
soldier and his personal pilot but as a
close friend as well his association
with moon knight and others often put
him in danger which saw the loyal
companion get beaten badly on occasion
and even required him to use cybernetic
leg enhancements at one point to walk
duchamp's closeness with mark was also
explored when the character came out as
gay but the two would continue to remain
just friends frenchie began dating his
physical therapist and opened a
restaurant though deschamps seems to
have moved away from the
action-adventure lifestyle in the comics
this easter egg implies he might have a
big role in the show one day
ethan hawke does an amazing job as the
primary antagonist of moon knight arthur
harrow but no one should be discouraged
if they don't recognize this particular
villain or know what he's about harrow
only appears in one issue of the comic
moon knight fists of khonshu issue 2
from 1985 though he makes an impression
in the issue it appears or the show
really wanted to use was his name the
actual comic book character was a
geneticist who studied the lens at which
humans experience and deal with pain
eventually creating soldiers who
couldn't feel it all of this knowledge
was gained from experiments that
involved torturing various subjects
mostly during world war ii the opening
scene of moon knight sees harrow putting
glass in his shoes and walking in them
as some type of self-flagellation and he
is shown to have an enormous number of
followers these aspects of the character
had most readers believing that he could
also be a version of the villainous sun
king but the powers and the fact that
harrow serves ahmed the soul eater don't
quite add up to that i judge you in
amit's name with but a fraction of her
power this makes sense why wouldn't the
creators save someone that hearts for
another adventure later on
there are a lot of great superhero
costumes but white isn't usually a major
color in them especially for vigilantes
he would make an entire suit white while
operating mostly after dark moon knight
that's who the explanation is simple
enough he's an avatar dispensing justice
a symbol for can't you spectre wants to
be seen and easily identifiable to
strike fear into his prey when he comes
after them but it also looks cooler when
he has their blood all over him in many
superhero movies the characters will
wear their preferred color schemes even
in their secret identities or normal
lives but it's usually a subtle
stylistic choice or a character's
natural affinity with someone like
stephen krantz who doesn't know about
his alternate identity yet it comes off
as more subconscious when he's seen
sporting a white t-shirt or hoodie this
adds an extra level to the concept of
grand attempting to figure out his true
nature and it's a neat little detail for
fans
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one